So this is a good start for a basic design for a pseudo-random number generator.
We have some pool of randomness, we extract a seed from that pool,
we use that seed as the key to our encryption algorithm,
and as the messages, we use a counter.
So suppose we use AES 128--so that means the key size and the block size
are 128 bits, and so each time we do this, we get 128 bits out.
which we use as our random values.
And this counter will go up to (2^128) - 1, and then go back to 0.
So now I have a quiz about how well this works.
So the question is: does this produce a sequence that appears random?
And let's say... for the first 2^70 outputs--so certainly if we have more than--
2^128 outputs, well, these countervalues repeat. So that would be non-random.
The choices are: "Yes," "No," because it repeats values too frequently,
or "No," because it repeats values too infrequently.